[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تواصل كتائب الثوار في مدينه
بنغازي استعدادها تحسبا لاي هجوم قد تشنه
قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر وكانت
المدينه قد شهدت منذ الجمعه الماضيه
مواجهات بين الجانبين جاءت بعد شهور من
الاضطرابات الامنيه والاغتيالات نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما الذي يفسر حاله الاستهداف
المستمر الذي تتعرض له بنغازي منذ ثوره
الساب عشر من
فبراير وما اهميه التصدي لما يجري في
بنغازي من اجل الحفاظ على منجزات الثوره
واستكمال البناء الديمقراطي في
ليبيا بعد اي ايام من اضطرابات شهدتها
بنغازي وراح ضحيتها عشرات الليبيين تحبس
المدينه انفاسها تحسبا لهجوم قد تشنه قوات
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر الذي وصف ثوار
بنغازي ما يقوم به بانه محاوله انقلاب
هدفها الاطاحه بالثوره بمساعده ولحساب قوى
اجنبيه اتهام ادرج في سياقه ما ظلت تشهده
بنغازي بدرجه اكبر من مثيلاتها من المدن
الليبيه منذ الاطاحه بنظام القذافي اواخر
عام 2001
كانت بنغازي منطلق ثوره الساب من فبراير
ضد القذافي ونظامه شكل بها في ال من مارس
عام
2011 المجلس المؤقت برئاسه مصطفى عبد
الجليل الذي لعب دورا حاسما في توجيه
الثوره والمحافظه عليها حتى انتصارها منذ
اغتيال اللواء عبد الفتاح يونس احد القاده
الميدانيين لثوره الساب عشر من فبراير في
يوليو عام 2011 وحتى الان تصدرت بنغازي
سائر المدن الليبيه من حيث عدد الاغتيالات
التي جرت فيها و 80% او نحو ذلك من
المغتالين ينتمون للاجهزه العسكريه
والامنيه ويشتركون في دورهم البارز في
الثوره على القذافي من منطلق وضعها هذا
مثلت بنغازي منذ بواكير انتصار الثوره
ساحه استعراض لمختلف القوى ولطالما انتقد
غياب سيطره الجيش والشرطه والامن عليها
وضعف قدره اجهزه الدوله على احكام السيطره
الامنيه والانعكاسات السالبه لذلك وفي
سياق اجواء الاغتيالات والانفلات الامني
جاءت الاحداث والتطورات الراهنه رغم
اختلاف طبيعتها التي تمثلت هذه المره في
الهجوم الجوي على معسكر الثوار الساب عشر
من فبراير واستهداف المدينه بريه من
محورين تحت عنوان القضاء على المجموعات
الارهابيه ثوار بنغازي وصفوا ما يقوم به
العقيد خليفه حفتر بانه محاوله انقلابيه
ينفذها لصالح قو اقليميه ليس في مصلحتها
استكمال ليبيا مسارها القرا وهو اتهام لا
ينفصل عن الجدل الذي تثيره شخصيه الرجل
منذ ايام اسره في تشاد مرورا بسنوات بقائه
في امريكا التي سحب اليها بعد سقوط حكومه
حسين هبري في تاد صحيح ان حفتر التحق
بثوره فبراير لكن اخفاقات ميدانيه عديده
حسبت عليه قبل ازاحته من الساحه حاول
مقاومتها من خلال محاوله انقلابيه فاشله
في ال 14ب عش من فبراير الماضي قبل ان
يعود ليفتح المعركه الراهنه بنغازي بنظر
منتقديه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا من
بنغازي المحلل السياسي عصام الجهاني ومن
طرابلس الكاتب والباحث السياسي صلاح
البكوش اهلا بضيفي الكريمين سيد صلاح بكوش
لماذا بنغازي خاصه في ما يجري في هذه
الايام اهلا
بك بنغازي هي مهد الثوره وكانت دائما
وابدا مركزا للمقاومه السياسيه والمسلحه
لنظام القدافي وعوقب على هذا الموقف على
مدى اربعه عقود وبما انها كانت هي شراره
الثوره ضد النظام القمعي المتمثل في نظام
القدافي فهي الان تعاقب تعاقب على ذلك
الموقف بطرق اخرى واعتقد ان هذه
الاغتيالات وهذه التفجيرات
والاختطاف هو ومسلسل في ثوره مضاده ضد 17
فبراير مسلسل يرتفع وينخفض
والان نشهد حلقه جديده في هذا المسلسل
بانقلاب
المدعو خليفه حفتر ا سيد عصام الجيهاني
ايضا لماذا بنغازي ما الذي يتوفر في
بنغازي حتى يسلط عليها كل هذا الضوء حتى
تشهد كل ما جرى حتى ما يجري هذه الايام
بين قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر وبين
الثوار في مدينه
بنغازي اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بنغازي شراره الثوره كيف ما تفضل ضيفك
بنغازي المتمرده بنغازي الجريحه بنغازي
التي تعاني الان من من خلال من مده خمس
قرون من خمس عقود واليوم تعاني من من من
ثوره من ثلاث سنوات اغتيالات وتفجيرات
وفوضه امنيه عارمه تعاقب هذا هذه المدينه
على ثورتها اذا نعرفه عرفنا من قبل موضوع
الثوار وكيف كيف انا نقول كتائب ثوار وكان
الطرف الاخر اللي هو الجيش الوطني نحن
طلبنا بالجيش الوطني من اول يوم قامت بها
هذه الثوره بدينا نطالبه بدوله المؤسسات
من ضمنها وعلى راسها الجيش الوطني نحن لنا
ثلاث سنوات نسمع في مصطلح الثوار من هو
الثائر اصلا الثائر الذي يتقاضى الان راتب
و ويؤتمن بامر رئيس اركان يحمل حقيبه في
يده في طرابلس اليوم لا نعرف مكانه اين ام
الثائر الذي يحمي هذا العرض والارض اعتقد
ان ان المصطلحات الان اصبحت جميعها فضفاضه
الثائر التي غمس معهم اشباه الثوار كانوا
كانوا الثوار 177000 او 13000 او 14000
وقفز هذا الرقم الى 220 ال فاصبحنا اليوم
لم نستطع تعريف او تحديد الثائر هذا
الثائر اليوم نحن نحن ليس ليس طيب في هذه
الحاله كيف تسمي كيف تسمي من هو مع عفوا
من هو مع اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر اذا
كان الثوار الان اصبحوا محل شبهه ماذا عن
الفريق الاخر كيف
تصفه الفريق الاخر قوات جيش عسكريين
العسكريين شاركوا في ثوره 17 فبراير في
برقا هناهي في برقا تحديدا وفي بنغازي
وجميع بدن برقه الجيش انشق يعني اذا اذا
الجيش انشق راس عبد الفتاح يونس الجيش كله
انشق وعلى راسه ايضا اللواء خليفه حفتر
وجا حظر من بدايه الثوره وشارك في هذه
الثوره المجيده ثوره 17 فبراير اذا ثلاث
ارباع الثوار ايضا من الجيش فبالتالي اذا
مصطلح الثوار وتعريف مصطلح الثوار والان
وكان نحن بخذ حرب ثوار ثوار ضد بعض لكن
نحن نقصد الجيش الوطني اليوم من الليبيين
اليوم التفاف كامل بشبه اجماع اليوم نسمع
في اعلانات في جميع المدن سواء في شرق
ليبيا او في غرب او في غرب ليبيا واخيرا
مصرات انا قبل ما نخرج من بيتي سمعت ان
مصرات خرجت ببيان قوي جدا جدا يتعلق
بكرامه هذه الامه المبعثره والتي لم يستطع
حتى الان وذين صنفنا من الثوار ان يحموا
بنغازي هناك حرب ش القريب والبعيد حرب ضي
سنعود لك سيد عصام سيد صلاح البكوش الان
السؤال الذي يلي لماذا
بنغازي لماذا خليفه حفتر من
يكون نعم شوف انا
انا هذا الشخص الذي
الان يخرج علينا بتعبيرات
الكرامه اذكر لك
قصه حضرتها
بنفسي عندما فك اسر خليفه حفتر
وبعض الجنود من الاسر في تشاد ونقلوا الى
واشنطن دي سي كنت هناك وذهبت انا والسيد
صالح جعوده ذهبنا بعد ان تلقينا مكالمه من
قص امريكي يقول لنا ان هناك جنود ليبيين
اتوا من تشاد ورمي في
كنيسته وذهبنا هناك ووجدنا هؤلاء الجنود
الليبيين في قبو كنيسه في اسوا منطقه في
واشنطن دي سي هناك يتغدون
ويفطرون وفي العشاء يجهزون لهم
سندوتشات بينما كان السيد خليفه حفتر يس
بينما كان السيد خليفه حفتر يسكن في شقه
فخمه في الدور ال 27 في نفس العماره التي
كنت اسكن فيها في الدور الساس والعش اين
هي كرامه الليبيين عندما كان خليفه حفتر
يسكن في هذه الشقه الفخمه وجنوده الذين
اسروا معه في تشاد يسكنون في قبوه
كنيسه مسيحيه في في اسوى مناطق واشنطن دي
سي علاقه سيد صلاح بكوش بما يجري الان سي
صلاح بما يجري الان لان لان تعريف شخصيه
من هو وراء هذه ستدل على ما هي دوافعه وما
هي مراميه السيد حفتر كما هي حال جميع
العسكريين في المنطقه العربيه على مدى
اكثر من خ خه قرون لم يخرج علينا وانا
اتحدى اي شخص ان يخرج علينا ببيان لانقلاب
عسكري لم يذكر فيه كرامه الشعب ومن اجل
الشعب وللشعب وهكذا ولكنهم استمروا في
الحكم ولم يزال من الحكم الا بانقلاب
عسكري او بموت مفاجئ السيد خليفه حفتر
يقود محاوله انقلابيه والتي والتي حاول ان
يقوم بها سته ايام قبل انتخابات لجنه 60
هيئه الدستور وفي ذلك الوقت وصفها السيد
علي زيدان الذي يدعمه الان بانها محاوله
سخيفه طيب سيد عصام سيد عصام الجهاني اذا
كان يجري الان نعم ساعود لك سيد صلاح
البكوش سيد عصام الجهاني اذا كان هذه هي
مرامي السيد خليفه حفتر كما يقول اعاده
الكرامه
لليبيين لماذا يتوجه الى بنغازي ولا يتوجه
الى العاصمه لماذا يستعمل السلاح ولا
يستعمل طرق اخرى هذا العمل وصف بالانقلاب
فكيف لنا ان نثبت عكس
ذلك سيدي الكريم ضيفك يخلط الاوراق خلط
الاوراق ويشخص في في القضيه
الليبيه كل ما يخرج حد يقوم بعمل في ليبيا
يتم تشخيص الامر لان الخصم الاخر يحاول ان
يجد اي ثغرات ليس مطب لاي شخص ولا يعنيني
اي شخص يعنيني الوطن
بصفت الشخصيه ولكن الاصطياد في الماء
العكر فيما يتعلق
بال اللواء خليفه حفتر او غير خليفه حفتر
اليوم نحن ريت نتحدث عن عبد الفتاح ي انت
تحكي نحن نحكوا على انشقاقات حصلت
انشقاقات حصلت على النظام السابق ومن ضمن
الانشقاقات هذاه عسكريين جل العسكريين
الليبيين ونحن
مالناش مش داعي نذكر الذين وقفوا مع
القذافي الى اخر لحظه ولكن لكن الذي انشق
وهذا خرج حتى قانون في المجلس الانتقالي
اللي انشق عليه نظام القذافي تحكي على
اللواء اللواء خليفه اللواء خليفه منشق
على القذافي من سنوات طويله عندما باعه
القذافي في حرب تشاد للفرنسيين لما عرف
القذافي طاقي القذافي عرف ان فرنسا تدخلت
في موضوع تشد نكر حتى اسم حفتر فبالتالي
الحديث تشخصن الامور وشخصت موضوع اليوم
القيادات العسكريه في جل ليبيا نحن نحكوا
على قيادات كامله انا ممكن اليوم نتحدث
معك ممكن خلال يومين او ثلاثه او اربع
ايام او خلال اسبوع تنتهي هذه الحرب نحن
ما ندخل البلد في حرب
اهليه عصام سيد عصام الحديث عف
الح
عع ولكن فقط حتى نضع النقاط على الحروف
الحديث بشكل عام ان هناك قطاعات باكملها
وهناك جل وهناك اغلبيه هذا كلام يمكن لاي
شخص من اي طرف ان يقول هذا الكلام ل نبقى
في يتعلق بسؤالي لماذا يتحرك على مستوى
بنغازي ولم يتم التحرك مثلا على مستوى
العاصمه طرابلس لماذا بنغازي تحديدا ما
الذي يجعل هذا اللواء المتقاعد ومن معه
سواء كان اغلبيه او اقليه يتحركون في
بنغازي
تحديدا بنغازي يا سيدي عاصمه ايضا بنغازي
وفق الدستور
51 الفقره 188 عاصمه للبلاد كما هي طرابلس
عاصمه للبلاد وبنغازي هي امتداد ل جميع
الحراك بنغازي هي شراره الثوره بنغازي اي
شيء يقوم يقوم من خلال بنغازي ليس تقصيرا
او ليس انقاص في حق طرابلس او في اي عاصمه
زي سبها او زي البيضا او زي طبرك او زي
زواره فانت تتحدث على بنغازي يا اخي
الكريم بنغازي هذه المدينه في وطن او وطن
في مدينه فالحديث نحنا الليبيين الان لما
تقول لي لا تجمع الليبيين يا ريت كم نحنا
ندير استفتاءات زي ما امريكا تعمل في
استطلاعات للراي يا ريت بس ندير استطلاعات
للراي بالنسبه للشخ الشارع نقول لا تبي
جيش وشرطه يا اخي طلعنا في جميع المظاهرات
وجميع مناطق ليبيا تطالب بالجيش والشرطه
اليوم
خرجت ما الذي يمنع يمنع ان يكون ما يقوم
به الان اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ذا
بعد وطني وليس كما يروج بعض وسائل الاعلام
او بعض الاقنيه بان هذا عمل بدوافع خارجيه
لاهداف ذاتيه وشخصيه الهدف منها النيل من
ثوره الساب عشر من فبراير وكذلك البناء
الديمقراطي ما الذي يمنع ان يكون هذا
العمل عملا
وطنيا الذي يمنعه يا سيدي مقوله ان من لا
يتذكر تاريخه حتما سيعيده نحن نتذكر تاريخ
العسكريين عندما ينغمسون في السياسه في
العالم العربي والمنطقه منطقه العالم
الثالث على مدى اكثر من 50 قرنا كانت كلها
اكذوبه كلما يخرجون علينا بمصلحه الشعب
لقد جر ربنا ذلك اذا اردنا ان نجرب ذلك من
جديد فاعتقد ان الغباء ربما يكون ايضا من
الحقوق حقوق الانسان ولكننا جربنا ذلك
القضيه يا سيدي اين كان حفتر وهؤلاء
الجنود
عندما كانت بنغازي تعاني هناك اكثر من
22000 عسكري بارقام عسكريه في منطقه
بنغازي العسكريه اين هم اين كانوا اين هم
الالاء عشرات الاف من رجال الامن في
بنغازي اين هم كانوا قابعون في
بيوتهم هذا هو الواقع لقد تاخر بناء الجيش
الليبي لعده عوامل لكن من اهمها هم هؤلاء
الضباط هناك ارب اكثر من 14000 ضابط في
الجيش الليبي يتزاحمون على كرسي رئيس
الاركان ويرفضون بعض وانتم على الجزيره في
مقابلات عده شاهدتم
ضباطا ضباطا يخرجون على الت هذه الحاله
سيد صلاح بكوش وكذلك ضيفي من بنغازي السيد
عصام الجهاني في هذه الحاله ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير سوف نناقش تاثير ما يحدث في بنغازي
على مسار الثوره ومحاولات استكمال البناء
الديمقراطي في ليبيا نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش اسباب وتفسيرات الاستهداف المستمر
الذي تتعرض له مدينه بنغازي وارحب بضيفي
في كل من بنغازي وكذلك من طرابلس سيد عصام
الجهاني هل ترى ما يحدث الان في بنغازي
على سبيل العينه يخدم مرامي وما ضحى من
اجله الليبيون في ثوره الساب عشر من
فبراير سيدي كريم سمعت سؤالك دوشه عندي
طيب سالتك ان كان ما يجري في بنغازي تصفه
الح الحكومه بانه محاوله انقلاب يصفه
الطرف الاخر بانه تطهير والعداله لاهل
بنغازي هل ما يجري يخدم اهداف ثوره الساب
عشر من
فبراير اخي كريم عرفتنا من قبل نحنا في
لقاءات سابقه عرفت الانقلاب الانقلاب انت
تحكي على دوله لما يكون فيها دوله فيها
مؤسسات قائمه بحكومات التشريعيه
بمات بجهازها التنفيذي بجهازها القضائي
ودوله عندها مؤسسات وفيها جيش مؤسسه
عسكريه كامله قائمه وبعدين هذك ساعه
نقولوا نحنا قام الجيش بانقلاب عسكري
على السلطه اللي هي جه التشريعيه ان بررد
على سؤال السيد ضيفك لما حكاه قال وين ال
عن سؤالي سؤال سيلاح عصام عف مات السؤال
بعك انت تحكي على الانقلاب
قنا كان مقدمه كان مقدمه سؤالي سؤالي
سؤالي هل ما يجري الان في بنغازي هو من
اهداف ثوره الساب عشر من فبراير او يتسق
مع
اهدافها
كل شيء لا يتفق مع اهداف ثوره 17 فبراير
لان نحنا ادخلنا البلد من البدايه ادخلنا
البلد كانوا كانوا الثوار الحقيقيين اللي
نتحدث عليهم الان كانوا الثوار الحقيقيين
في الجبهات وكانوا في ناس كانوا يعملوا
مخالف الستار اللي هم ضيعوا البلد حتى هذه
اللحظه ادخلوا البلد في متاهه سياسيه
وكارثه قفزوا على وحرقوا المراحل حرقوا
المراحل كيف من خلال المجلس الانتقالي
باعلان دستوري مهلهل اعلان دستوري كارثي
على البلد الان اوصل البلد لهذه المرحله
ادخلوا الاحزاب في في في العمليه السياسيه
من ضمنها حزب الاخوان المسلمين الذي لديه
اجنده خارجيه خارج اجنده الوطن و وشاهدنا
في من خلال المؤتمر كتله الوفاء التي لما
يسمى التيار الاسلامي السياسي والذي اخرجت
بلد لهذ لهذا النفق اللي نحن موجودين فيه
الان فبالتالي هو هذا السؤال هذا ردا على
السؤال اليوم المواطن الليبي محتاج الامن
اليوم المواطن كان كان يسعى من خلال 17
فبراير كان يسعى الى دوله المؤسسات
والديمقراطيه ويبدا بناء الدوله ولكن الان
يطلب الامن يطلب الامن من من يطلبها من
الثوار الثوار اللي هم الان ثلاث سنوات
لانهم غير منظمين لان في بعض بعض اشباه
الثوار يدفعوا اجنتات احزاب معينه ننا
نشهد اليوم في ليبيا احزاب لد ما ذكرته
والان الى ضيفي في طرابلس السيد صلاح
البكوش هل تتفق مع من يقول بان ما يجري في
ليبيا ليس الهدف منه صراعات بسيطه بقدر ما
المستهدف بالاساس هي ثوره الساب عشر من
فبراير وما افرزته في
ليبيا بها شعب سؤالي موجهسي صلاح ل كنت
اطلع على على على
استجواب لاحد الخبراء امام الكونجرس
الامريكي اول
امس وما يقوله هو هو الواقع يقول ان تصوير
الصراع في بنغازي كانه صراع بين جيش وطني
وارهابي
وارهابيين هو تصور مسطح
وخالي من المعقوليه ان الصراع في بنغازي
هو صراع سياسي على السلطه بين اطراف
سياسيه ومسلحه وجهو وقبليه هذا هو الصراع
الذي يحدث في بنغازي الان من لم يستطع
تحقيق مقاربه من تحت قبه المؤتمر الوطني
العام يتحول الان الى محاوله تحقيقها عن
طريق السلاح وهل هناك بعد خارج صلاح هل
هناك بعد خ هناك
تصريحات شوف هناك انا لست من المؤمنين
بنظريات المؤامره جميع الاطراف الخارجيه
لها مصالح في ليبيا وتريد لمصالحها ان
تنجح ليبيا لديها مصالح في دول الجوار
ونريد حكومات صديقه لنا في تشاد والنيجر
ومص صر هذه القضيه هي ما الذي تريد ان
تفعله الدوله ومواطنيها تجاه هذه المصالح
نحن لا نريد هذه المصالح ان تطغى على
المشهد السياسي وان تسير امورنا ولكنها
يعني لا ياتيني احد بجديد عندما يقول لي
ان هناك دول لها مصالح في ليبيا ولها
اجندات في ليبيا لها امريكا لها اجندات في
روسيا وروسيا لها اجندات في امريكا
وبريطانيا لها اجندات في فرنسا وفرنسا لها
اجندات في افريقيا ما ما جديد في ذلك لكن
التحليل الواقعي يقول بان هؤلاء الناس
يريدون الوصول الى السلطه اما ان نضحك على
انفسنا وندفن راسنا في الرمال ونتصور ان
السيد حفتر لما
ينتصر حيقول يا بنغازي او خلصك من
الارهابيين السلام عليكم انا ماشي لبيتي
هذا ضحك على
الدجون سيد عصام الجهاني ما الذي يستطيع
ان يغن على بلد ينتشر فيه السلاح اكثر من
الخبز اكثر من 20 مليون قطعه سلاح في
ليبيا يراهن بانه باستعمال القوه يمكن ان
يفرض امرا واقعا يعني ما هي الحسابات في
بلد بهذه الحساسيه وبهذا الانتشار الكثيف
للسلاح بالنسبه للسلاح حتى اليمن فيها
حوالي 100 قطعه مليون 100 مليون قطعه سلاح
يعني السلاح في امريكا موجود السلاح
اهم في اليمن في 100 مليون قطعه سلاح وفي
امريكا ايضا الاشخاص يملون اسلحه لكن كيف
نحن كيف نحن بالنسبه لليبيين بالنسبه
لليبيا هنا نحن دخلا علينا زي ما نحن
حرقنا المراحل وقفظ على المراحل وادخلنا
البلد من خلال من خلال المجلس الانتقالي
بدايه بالمجلس الانتقالي حتى وصولنا الى
نكبه الامه اللي هو المؤتمر الوطني اللي
انتخب الشعب المسكين اللي هو مش عارف ان
هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين انتخبهم تحولوا من
اشخاص كانوا شعبيين من خلال الشعب كانهم
ضحكوا على الشعب تحولوا الى احزاب والى
والى الى اجندات اخرى ولكن في هذه سيد عص
سيد عصام ايض ايضا سي سيقال لك هؤلاء
انتخبهم الشعب ايا كانت الظروف السياسيه
من يخاصم هؤلاء باي شرعيه يتكلمون باي
مبرر اخلاقي الان ينصبون من انفسهم ومنصات
حتى يقولوا بان هذا مخطئ وهذا
مصيب انت تتكلم من حقك يا اخي انت تتكلم
عن الشرعيه اي شرعيه سي ك عفوا انا اسال
فقط سؤال منطقي هؤلاء انتخبهم الشعب عفوا
انتخبهم الشعب يخ طيب
طيب طيب او اي شرعيه نحن ما عندنا شرعيه
يا اخي الكريم نحن شرعيتنا 7عه اين انتهت
خلاص او 17 اثنين او 7 اثنين انتهت
الشرعيه نحن مددت الشرعيه واغتصبت الان
100 يوم فاي شرعيه تتحدث عليها يا ريت هذه
الشرعيه والله على الاقل اسست نوعا ما جزء
ولو 10% في الدوله الشرعيه هذه تتكالب على
الدوله الان نحن نسمع في اموال تنهب وتخرج
الى الخارج تذهب الى دول الجوار كانت
تساعد في مصر في حزب ال ل للاخوان في مصر
يعني انتم تتحدثوا على دعم لميليشيات نحن
ما نعرفها نحن اليوم في ناس قبضت على
اجانب قاعدين في ليبيا ماش عارف اجندات
ناس تقتل تقتل في ابنائنا في بنغازي وفي
درنا وفي وفي برسس وفي اي و في كل مناطق
ليبيا ط سيد سيد صلاح بكوش حديث على
السلاح والحديث طيب سيده صلاح بكوش برايك
الى اين تتوجه او تتجه الامور في ظل
التقارير وما تقول بان مساله الحسم
بالسلاح لن يكون هينا في ليبيا وبالتالي
كيف سيكون المخرج في هذه
الحاله المخرج في هذه الحاله هو الاحتكام
الى العقل والاعتماد على الحقائق اما ما
يقوله ضيفك من بنغازي فهذه افتراضيات و1
مليون في اليمن والمؤتمر الوطني ارسل فلوس
للاخوان في مصر يعني يعني هذا ممكن كان
يلعب به علينا نوعيه هذا الكلام يلعب به
علينا القدافي و وكذا ولكن الان اذا اردنا
بناء دوله مدنيه ديمقراطيه يجب ان نعتمد
على الحقائق ويجب ان ندعم ما نقول به
بالحقائق الان كلنا كلنا متفقين على ان
الارهاب او ما
تسميه التشكيلات المسلحه الخارجه عن سيطره
الدوله والقتل والاغتيالات مرفوضه رفضا
كاملا من الشعب الليبي الان نريد ان نجد
حلا لهذه معضله هذا الحل يجب ان يعتمد
اولا على الحقائق وليس
الفرضيات اشكرك ثانيا يجب ان لا نقفز الى
اول حل يخطر على البال لكي نخلق مشكل اخر
اشكرك سيد صلاح بكوش الكاتب والباحث
السياسي كنت معنا من طرابلس كمان اشكر
ضيفي من بنغازي المحلل السياسي عصام
الجهاني الى اللقاء باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
ا